what do I look for in a role I think I
look for things that interest me I think
I look for things that I don't quite
understand and things that I want to
explore I look for things to be
difficult I don't want it to be easy and
if it feels like I know exactly how to
do it as soon as I read it I'm not
really that interested it's always got
to kind of be a challenge I'm looking
for something a bit different from what
I have been doing usually in a role and
I'm looking but I'm mainly looking for
truth and integrity even um no matter
what it is even if it's a comic cameo
there's still got to be a truth behind
it and I like the whole it not just I'm
not just looking at my character obvious
I'm looking at the whole thing I like I
like the thought that it works for me
it's it's really exciting if you you
know you have a character that has an
arc that you know learn something you
know I like roles where you get a chance
to transform you know not just
physically but you know emotionally and
to be able to play a strong female
character I'm pretty bad at reading
scripts although I do a lot of it let's
say you think that I would have got
better but I'm not brilliant at it so I
take a lot of advice I'll get other
people to and to read stuff as well you
know if they have the time and the
inclination also a pretty good judge is
if I'm reading the script and I don't
want to either throw it at the wall or
flush it down the toilet or just put it
down if I keep reading it then that's a
pretty good indicator and then after
that it's who's going to direct it who's
going to be in it and that sort of thing
and where is it going to be shot in
terms of preparing it really depends on
the role and I think the director and
the type of material if if it's a period
piece for example I try and do research
about the period you know look at
historical material but I got into a lot
of research with a foe I did called
Dangerous Method and then I didn't
actually all around that period it was
very very research heavy so it would be
whatever the thing was bay
Starlin then I'd go off on a tangent and
read just absolutely everything from
technically I just go over and over and
over and over and over the script as
many times as possible to try make the
dialogue sort of muscle memory the older
I get the more prepared I feel I need to
be on every level I never used to learn
lines until the night before but now I
don't do that anymore they have to be
committed to long-term memory as opposed
to short-term memory generally speaking
that you can't always do that but that's
right I try to do so I usually have a
good grasp of the script and I read the
script a number of times and I try and
break the script down into a timeline to
see if I understand the beginning in the
middle and the end and also if there are
flashbacks is where I get quite confused
so I'll you know I'll do a couple of
timelines to see if I if it all makes
sense to me so that I can track there
the journey you want to know who the
person is even though you might only be
in five minutes of the script that day
so I will do my own rehearsals as if I
was rehearsing with the director really
on my own I did a movie last year called
beyond the lights where I had a lot of
singing and dancing and so that became
part of the preparation you know
watching music videos having singing
lessons dance training and obviously
that's not required for every role so if
I can I'll go and meet people who do the
particular job of the character that I'm
being asked to play I mean if it's a if
it's a period piece that's slightly more
difficult I'll generally read around the
topic if it's a writer who's read out
their written other stuff then I would
you know go and look at their other
material in terms of a successful
collaboration between actor and director
I think it's really about understanding
the vision of the director understanding
the point of view also listening it's
sort of so simple but it's such a key
thing in any sort of artistic creative
collaboration the directors I've loved
most have been the ones who are very
free who are open to people's
suggestions no matter who it is people
like Steven Daldry he'd suddenly say
let's just shoot another scene here now
let's why don't we you know let's make
let's say they're in this room and this
happens
we'll just choose another scene that we
would talk about in the cabin and then
just do it yeah I just loved that I
don't think that I could talk about
directors and not talk about Joe right
because we've done three films together
you know and I think that collaboration
has to be the most important of my
career we have a working relationship
that isn't necessarily comfortable but
it is quite challenging is always
supportive but it's not like but we've
got this weird thing what we sort of
don't need to speak to each other so
even when we're disagreeing it's not
like we're really doing it verbally
we're sort of sort of doing it with mime
and looking at something you know and I
think particularly when I first sort of
started working at with him it was a
time when I was getting a lot of
criticism from everywhere and he was
sort of the first person that said to me
you can really do this and you need to
work hard and put your head down and so
obviously you know I've always hugely
appreciated him for that I don't like
being over directed some people feel
that they have to be seen to be
directing you know and they come in and
give you a note after every thing and
because you're the only thing you've got
your instincts so if there and they can
be interfered with sometimes rather than
nurtured and I find that to be then you
start to doubt them when I work with
Stephen Frears on tomorrow drew I
suddenly realized when I saw how he
works with all his other crew that he
just brings people in who he trusts he
entrusts you to do your job he doesn't
you know ask you did your job if he
doesn't think you can't do it he thinks
you can't do it and so that was really
wonderful to go oh I see you're just
you're just letting me do what I can do
and it's it that's really exciting to
know that someone goes yeah you know I
trust you pearls of wisdom I don't know
if I feel experienced enough to have
great wisdom I mean for me it's really
been a case of working hard and being
determined
I tell make sure you really want it
because it's a hard road if you don't
there's a lot of rejection you've got to
really believe in yourself we've got a
poster on our on our kitchen wall which
is a painting in the National Portrait
Gallery of the back of Samuel Beckett's
head
watching a production of Waiting for
Godot and on the bottom it's a thing
that he used to say which was no matter
try again fail again fail better we must
be more brave about failing and of
dealing with rejection the rejection is
not personal it's not personal it's
necessary yeah it's a really hard
profession you know I mean you've got to
love it
you've got an in it is a vocation
it doesn't like of it's not a vocation
because you are going to get trampled
down you are going to get people saying
no and and you have to have that thing
where you can't do anything else because
then you know then you are an actor so I
think it's you know keep on keep on keep
on keep on and also get a job I would
say that to two young actors starting
out is get a normal job a real job that
you can work around auditions and
whatever so that you're hanging out with
real people because that's those are the
people you were hopefully going to
people training unless you're you know
the sort of person that's going to
portray a lot of serial killers if you
become famous don't believe any of the
hype because that's all it is really
it's all a mirage you know just believe
in yourself